hi I'm River grin that I'm a BuzzFeed
and I'm having some staring competitions
with some fans I didn't got blinked
doing that
[Music]
ok ok ok ready 1 2
hello how are you good
my eyes are so dry right hey how's your
day going very kids how's heels it's
it's going yeah how you doing good
they haven't um blink Wow still going ok
how do I win rip up your face oh I'm
gonna get closer oh my god nice
okay you're really nice guys thanks a
nicety thank you ah that was good
[Applause]
what's that hey okay I'm very
competitive good thank you
but also I'm dying inside you play I
just gave you a bit my breath oh I
didn't blame you please just blame ah
you believers okay okay Bowser baby haha
quite imitating thank you I think I
blame well if ever I thought you you had
it I thought I had it too but I think
here is such a fun summer is a hilarious
front of the entire week watching Harry
Potter I watched it for the first time
this week as well
really yeah how did you know I always
hate watching myself but I think this is
you've never know you can't know the
first one I probably most bits of it
you're getting three wait wait am i
starting now I have to keep my eyes open
now yep three two what
oh I'm twits you
yeah we just could do you think you're
so cool cuz you're a celebrity well I'm
gonna grab your lanyard okay a little
bit of this nice that was good I thought
you had it
[Music]
I'm shaking five three two one oh my god
hey dick hi oh my god oh yes three two
what
you're getting I'm gonna get closer yeah
okay no yeah
do you wear contacts no I don't mean
apparently to what oh okay hi hi how are
you I'm great
are we good oh I've linked I don't lose
knees oh you'll get uh-huh
Oh bling 11 nil I feel pretty good about
that I'm Paraguay good and I think I
beat ice cube so yeah apparently more
intimidating an ice cube I'll definitely
take that
[Music]